This morning we're continuing on in our firm foundations series where we're
looking at the truths that are outlined in our statement of faith and this
morning we've come to our statement on humanity which you can find at the back
of your worship guides there at the bottom it says we believe that man was
created in the image of God to glorify him by enjoying him forever.
Let's pray together.
Lord we thank you so much for your word Lord that you have not left us in this
world to just feel our way through the darkness to try to find out either who
you are or who we are or why we are here. Lord you've revealed yourself to us in
your word you have shown us your will for us in your word so that I pray that
you would open our eyes now as we look to your word together to see what
you would have to say to us this morning and that you would work in our hearts
that we might be ready to respond as you would have us to respond in Jesus' name
amen. Well there's a scene in the movie Gladiator I don't know if you've
seen that classic but it's a great scene where Russell Crowe's character
Maximus is standing in the arena and you know he was Rome's most trusted
general before but now he's unjustly lost not only his position but his
family and even his freedom and he's been a slave and he's been forced to
compete in the gladiatorial games and so now as he stands in the arena he is
right before the emperor who has betrayed him and that emperor doesn't
recognize who he is he's there with his mask on and is back to him and that
emperor demands that he says who he is like what is your name he repeats
several times and and so he has to turn around and he takes off his mask
and then he finally sees who he is when he takes off his mask he gives that
classic quote says my name is Maximus Decimus Meridius commander of the armies
of the north loyal servant to the true emperor father to a murdered son
husband to a murdered wife and I will have my vengeance in this life or the
next. So yeah here's a guy who's lost everything he's lost his position but
he clearly knows who he is and what his purpose is in terms of how he would put
it and it's something about movies like that that that resonate with us where
somebody's you know kind of wrestling with their identity and purpose or or
they clearly know who they are and what they are there to do and the reason
why that resonates with us is because these are two of the most fundamental
questions we can ask in our lives who am I and why am I here questions
about identity and purpose shape so much of our lives the vital questions but you
know modern Western culture has had some really misguided attempts especially in
recent decades to help us to answer these vital questions when you look back to
previous generations or even more traditional cultures today your identity
and your purpose is far more tied to your community like whose son you are like
where the family lives what what maybe what the family business is things like
that maybe your name like it could be like a Smith or a Mason something like
that speaks to like in your family history what what the family did right
so that identified in the name that kind of that community identity but
in recent decades we've been told to look where to find our identity we've
been told time and time again to look within ourselves to find our true
identity and purpose you discover who you truly are by looking inwardly at your
desires and your feelings and then you express that once you discover that you
express that identity to the world around you then the kind of expectation
now that identity and one of the more obvious examples of the way that has
gone haywire within our own generation is with the gender confusion that exists
where you even look within to discover what gender you are and then express
that into the world and expect other people to affirm that just to point you
to a good resource that delves far more deeply into how we think about
identity and purpose in our culture is there's an author called Carl Truman
who wrote a book called the rise and triumph of the modern self so if
you're looking for a read that's a good one to look into how do we think
about identity today and like where does it come from historically we just kind
of think well this is just how people think was actually were caught up in a
cultural moment there's an abridged version of it as well that I've been
told is very good so you can read that one if you want to show to read it's
called strange new world but most important is not for us to look to
our community around us for our sense of self or to look within ourselves
for our sense of who we are and what our purpose is rather to look to God
so that's what we're gonna do this morning we're gonna look to our
creator and to his word and to see what it says about who we are and why we are
here so we're gonna look at those two questions so first of all who are we
what does it mean to be human or to personalize that what does it mean for
me to be me well there's at least three things in Genesis one that tells us
about who we are so here in the opening account of Genesis we're given
this account of creation God is the presented to us has the creator of
the world and everything in it and he rules over his creation and that
includes us so we are his creation so the first thing we see about ourselves
is that we are creatures so Genesis one twenty six to twenty seven God
creates humanity and then he speaks about our nature and our purpose
Genesis two the creation of mankind is then expanded upon and described in more
detail as God creates Adam and Eve and speaks about what they are to do it's
then repeated in Genesis five you get to chapter five we're told again that God
created created humanity and he and he named us it gives us that distinct
thing there he calls us Adam which is a it was a word for the first man but
there's also a general word used to describe humanity as a whole so God
names us so what are we to draw from just that fact that we are put there in the
creation accounts that we are creatures and our creatureliness points us to
several truths but let me just give you a couple one is it points us to where
our identity comes from God is the one who names us he gives us our identity
so whatever our culture may tell us identity is not something that we create
it's not something that we achieve it is something that we receive from God we are
designed by him and his design is good and we are to look to him and how he
designed us for our identity to receive what he has fearfully and wonderfully made
Psalm 139 says all right so he's designed as his design is good so our
identity comes from him but also it speaks to how we live out our identity so if we
are created that means we are not self-made as creatures we are dependent upon our creator
by the way this this relieves the exhausting pressure to define ourselves or to to make
something of ourselves you of course that can have forms of like looking within ourselves to
constantly be trying to find out who we are but also you know there's been another move where
we look outside ourselves and what we do or accomplish for our identity some people live
by the batman philosophy to quote another movie and batman begins he says it is not who I am on
the inside but who but what I do that defines me and some people think in that way it's not
who I am on the inside but what I do and so you know they overwork or they're constantly
second guessing what they say do for a living or whatever because they're looking to what they do
to fulfill their identity and that's a terrible way to live so God invites us instead of trying to
prove ourselves to rely upon his grace to be the people he has made us to be and to rest in him
and part of that is being limitations we depend on him and work together with others because
we're not looking to our work for our sense of self or identity but there is something that is
really special about humanity yes we're creatures but we're a special creation so in verse 27 we're
told three times repeatedly we were created we were created we were created but Hebrew scholars point
out that this is a way of drawing special attention to us as God's creation so it's not just
saying we were created this kind of repeating it three time is a way of saying humanity is the
culmination of creation right so so you have this narration of creation that's kind of making
its way up a mountain and then you get to the pinnacle and it's the creation of humanity and all
along as God has created he's noted that everything he creates is good it's good it's good but now
that he creates humanity he says it's very good so there's a specialness to humanity
in our opening scripture Psalm A the psalmist is seeing this and thinking this through as he looks out
at the vastness of creation he says what is man that you are mindful of him so what is so special
about us creatures I guess the second thing we see about who we are is that we are image
bearers we're image bearers let's read verse 27 so God created man in his own image in the
image of God he created him male and female he created them so we were created in God's own image
probably should have read verse 26 first but let's let's read backwards let's go back to verse 26
and God said let us make man in our own image and after our likeness and it follows on that
he does what he has purpose in creating us so what makes humanity special is the fact that
we are created in the image of God another way to say this there is an intrinsic value to every human
life this isn't because of their capacities or because of their usefulness to society
but by virtue of their very humanity and so therefore every single human life every person
should be treated with the dignity and respect that comes with being an image bearer of God
so on the whole you know our culture in this moment would agree with that it's not always
reflected in our language in our language or behavior but most people agree with say the
notion of universal human rights we have to ask the question like why do we believe in that
how is it that we've gotten the point we're generally speaking people believe that I would
like to say that they believe in that if we are just a product of a random process then what basis
do you have to say that you equally value all human life well Christians actually have a really
good answer for that we value all human life because we are image bearers of God
so this is true regardless of someone's sex or ethnicity or ability
or socioeconomic status or immigration status or their age as applies to the unborn or the
elderly or infirm we ought to value every person and treat them with respect and resist
say for example the dehumanizing language that sometimes used in this heated cultural
moment to speak about other people so what does it mean for us to be created in God's image well
this is a major theme that you can trace throughout the storyline of scripture so we're just going
to scratch the surface of this just look at a couple things so to say we are image bearers
first of all is to say that we are God's royal representatives all right so in the in the
ancient world kind of like Old Testament Bible times across the world there'd be kings and you'd
probably living in under under the reign of some king and the way these kings would show the extent
of their dominion was by sending out these like statues these images of themselves and they'd
have these images everywhere to show the extent of their reign so if you were to travel maybe
from ancient Shinara who who reigns over over over all things if you don't know who he is just look
at the sign like right outside our building here and so Genesis is written and spoken in this
and this in this moment where that is happening in the world around the people of Israel
and here what are we seeing here that's that the God who created and reigns over everything
intended from the start to fill his creation with those who would bear his likeness
and represent him and his reign over all things and that's us so we are the image bearers the
statue so to speak of of God you see that in the the kind of royal aspect of us being
representatives in the language of dominion here and so verse 26 let them have dominion
be fruitful and multiply verse 28 and fill the earth and subdue it and have dominion
and then you have this kind of kingdom language being used throughout the scriptures we see that
in the kingdom of Israel we see that in the coming of Christ the king we see that as his kingdom
is proclaimed or as we're told to pray your kingdom come your will be done and then we eventually see
the kingdom that will never end as he reigns forever and forever it's all going back here to what we
see in in Genesis so we were created by God to be his royal ambassadors is another way of putting
it putting it as representatives of the king in the world then when you come to Genesis 5 let me
turn there and you see another aspect of like another angle on what it means to be an image bearer of
God and that is to be an image bearer of God is to be a child of God so in Genesis 5 what do we read
there this is the book of the generations of Adam when God created man he made him in the likeness
of God so you have that repeated again male and female he created them and he blessed them and
named them man when they were created okay we've seen that already then verse 3 when Adam had lived
130 years he fathered a son in his own likeness after his image and named him Seth so here we see
another aspect of what it means to bear God's image and likeness because the same language is
now used to speak of Adam having a son so God creates Adam in his own image and now Adam has
a son named Seth and he is in his image so what does that tell us about being image bearers well to
be someone's image bearers is to bear their likeness as their children like as a son as a daughter
so this speaks of one thing is is the degree of likeness you know he's looked at this a couple
of weeks ago you ask children bear resemblance to their parents so we bear a resemblance to God
so you might think well God is spirit how can we bear a resemblance to to God are we thinking like the
Sistine Chapel here what are we what are we talking about well the answer is we bear resemblance to
God in our character right so the invisible God is made visible in the world as we reflect
his likeness in our character and walking in his ways as we reflect his his holiness his love
his love his justice his his mercy and so on this also speaks to the source of our likeness we are to
be like him because we were created to be his children so image bearers are created not only
to be ambassadors of the king but also children of the king who bear in the family likeness
and that language is going to go on to be used like the kingdom language throughout scripture
so Israel is God says this in Exodus 4 22 says thus says the Lord Israel is my firstborn son
right so God calls his people to live as his children and as they live as his children they
are living as his royal representatives in the world you see the next is 19 and verse 6
where it actually connects those two the New Testament would go on to use this language
about Jesus he's the beloved son and it speaks about us as the church we are children of God
but and it can be restored through Christ but let me just make a quick kind of side
point here but it's crucial to what we're saying here is that the image is still present in
every person regardless of whether or not they are a Christian the image of God is present in
every human being although it's broken it's marred for sure but the image of God is still present
and if you want just an example to look at this you could look at Genesis 9 6 and this is after the
fall of man God still uses the language of them being created in his image to describe the whole
of humanity even after the fall okay so all of us bear the image of God or image bearers
one more thing though about who we are created to be image bearers but also as embodied souls
okay we are embodied souls years ago when I was first starting to preach I remember quoting
c.s. Lewis and here is the quote you don't have a soul you are a soul you have a body
now there's two problems with that quote from c.s. Lewis one is c.s. Lewis never said it
and two it's just not true it's not true when God created humanity he didn't just create us as bodies
and he didn't just create us as souls we are embodied souls okay it's what it means to be human
so there's two ditches to avoid here one is the ditch of materialism where we think about ourselves
or or the world around us but but we're thinking about humanity specifically as just being part
of the material world and there's nothing that's immaterial about who we are so we're just bodies
but there's another ditch to avoid where we think of ourselves primarily as well we we're
souls we're we're spiritual beings and one day we're just gonna leave our bodies behind and
that's our kind of eternal existence is a disembodied existence that's what we are looking forward to
that's not the hope that is given to us in scripture and we'll look more about that in
future weeks in terms of our our eternal hope but the bible presents this vision of who we are
here in genesis but throughout scripture of us being created in God's image both as soul and
body together but yet there's another kind of materialism and spiritualism and to get on a
little rabbit trail there's another kind of modern form of that kind of spiritual way of just thinking
of ourselves as souls rather than our bodies being important is just a kind of disembodied
existence online like you are your ideas and what is projected on the internet you know where the
primary way we kind of interact with each other is just like through those ideas and we kind of
you can see how people dehumanize one another in the comment sections of different different
things online and how they speak things they would never say in person just when we're like in the
same room physically present with one another we treat one another as as just an idea and reduce
people down to their their kind of thoughts or their their words rather than their their full
human existence okay let's get back to what we're looking at so this is part of God's good
design for us without this shared this shared humanity we have a misguided view of of who we are
but there's another aspect of us being embodied souls which which Genesis speaks to specifically
and that is our embodiment is spoken of in relation to our gender and sexuality as well
okay so humanity is created it's clear male and female and Jesus then goes on to affirm exactly
that in the gospels as well so in what it what it says here there's there's two things one there's
there's a really important sameness for us to see men and women both male and female both are
equal image bearers of God in fact in Genesis 2 when eve is brought to Adam
he emphasizes the sameness of eve to him actually he says finally this is now bone of my bone and
flesh of my flesh so there's an equality that is to be celebrated there but also there are
important distinctions male is still male and female still female right so there's equal
dignity and this maleness and female this is part of God's good design for us so without this shared
dignity and distinct complementarity we would be unable to fulfill our our god given purpose
to fill the earth with his glory so let's get into that so who are we we are image bearers of
God embodied souls who are created to be his royal representatives in the world this is the
identity God has given us so why are we here what is our purpose well if you've ever traveled abroad
and you go through customs and immigration they'll they'll ask you the question you know
what is the purpose of your visit and I don't know about you but I get really nervous traveling
through immigration like I don't think I'm carrying drugs I don't think I'm a smuggler or
but you just feel nervous and guilty about nothing and you kind of travel up there and
ask what's your purpose and they sometimes you know explain it like business or pleasure
and you gotta like I'm gonna do business or something and you think through it oh well our
statement on humanity is a very brief purpose kind of statement there but it includes both business
and pleasure so to speak we are here to glorify God by enjoying him forever and that's a that's
a great summary all right but I want to see it specifically in Genesis 1 about our purpose
the purpose of our life here on earth and the main thing is that our purpose flows from our
identity so everything we've said about our identity is what shapes our purpose in the world too
so you know a US ambassador traveling to a current country will will do things differently to a
tourist who's visiting that same country right so they their their purpose shapes or their
identity rather shapes their purpose in the country and what they do so image bearers have an
ambassadorial purpose to fulfill okay so we are gods representatives in the whole world and so
how do we do that well it involves three things one it involves reflecting God's glory in the
world we were made to reflect the glory of God you can think of that as you know like
a mirror is probably the simplest easiest image to think of here you know we were we were not made
as gods but that we might face God and thus reflect his glory in the world like so an image reflecting
who he is okay so we've we've already seen that this happens as we reflect the character of God
but another way of looking at this is that we glorify our king by living as king demagants
in the world following the ways of his kingdom so yes we abide by the laws of the land but we
live in such a way that makes it clear that we are citizens of heaven like we follow a greater king
so it's through our obedience that we glorify the Lord to put it just simply you see this in
exes 19 it was through the obedience of Israel that the nations would see that they are a
kingdom of priests that they are God's kingdom representatives so our way of life should demonstrate
which kingdom we ultimately belong to so in our in our household we've got some British things that
still lingered and one of them is an actual red coat that occasionally makes its appearance to
different things and it's been worn to school or to soccer practice things things like that
so there's just clear differentiation I'll tell you what kingdom I'm from you know
and I'm not saying we should all follow and see don't
but it should be clear by our you think this in the way it illustrates by our our accent by the
by the way we live that our kingdom the kingdom we belong to is not of this world there's something
different about how we live that speaks about where our true identity lies I should be seen
in how we treat one another as well as in our worship so God is glorified when his image bearers
show forth his likeness through conformity to his character and his ways all right so reflect
God's glory but secondly we were also made to rule God's creation so God created us we saw
in Genesis one to have dominion so humanity was made to rule over creation in a way that kind
of that imitates over creation we go to Genesis two what's Adam doing he's gardening so we rule over
creation through the the care and cultivation of creation so he's Adam's Genesis two he's naming
the animals but he's also tending to the Garden of Eden that's a garden that God himself is planted
so God is a gardener and Adam is imaging God by his own care and cultivation of that garden
and this of course is not limited to to gardening right this is just the early days like how do we
do this now on day one how do we rule over creation in this space but as the human family expands
and like in the towns forming and and we're looking at different ways to to harness the
good creation that God has made to bring about you know so things like you know God has created
grains so we take the grain and are able to make bread through that you know God hasn't created
tables but he has created trees and so we know how can we harness that and you know to create that
and so that's that spreads all the way throughout the world and so now you have this kind of
development of
of the world and that's part of what we are created to to do so you see that of course in the kind of
amazing innovations that have taken place throughout history but also as we participate in the
created order wherever we find ourselves that's part of what it means to to rule over creation
for the glory of God so that applies to your work however you work or wherever that is as you
tend to your corner of creation you can glorify God in that so God isn't just glorified when we
worship him together on a Sunday he intends to be glorified throughout the week in what you
do so God is glorified in the changing of diapers so God is glorified in landscaping
God is glorified through public service or mopping a high school gymnasium floor or running a business
whatever it is whatever you eat whatever you drink whatever you do do all to the glory of God
1 Corinthians 10 31 a few weeks ago we we saw Paul's ambition to preach the gospel where
Christ has not been named and we're called to participate in that but it's interesting that
word ambition is also used in 1 Thessalonians chapter 4 in verse 11 it begins with the word
aspire but it's the same word for ambition be ambitious in this to live quietly and to mind
your own affairs and to work with your hands so be ambitious now but glorify God by working
with your hands all right so we're to to rule over creation so reflect God's glory
in the everyday and then we're to thirdly reproduce God's image so God gives further instruction to
Adam and Eve he says be fruitful and multiply so in the creation accounts it's repeated that the
creation elements are to reproduce after their kind and then it gets to humanity and the same
thing is said so God intends to fill the earth with his glory through the multiplication of his
image bearers and this is one of the reasons why he created us male and female and instituted
marriage so he intends for us to have children and to to fill the earth with image bearers
and as humanity obeys God is king and multiplies throughout the earth his glory is then reflected
in all the earth and they all lived happily ever after right well that's not what we see as we
continue to read in Genesis and onward what happens sin comes into the world
instead of following the command of the king as royal representatives Adam and Eve rebel against the king
and they they do their own thing instead of reflecting his character they break his command
when sin enters the world like like a like that mirror reflecting the image of God the the mirror
is then shattered it's cracked the image of God in us is broken man can we do some terrible
things too with the created world and it's fraught with difficulty even when we do good things with
creation and Adam and Eve yeah they were fruitful and they multiplied their first son what did he do
killed his brother and then you see throughout Genesis the multiplication not only of people
but of sin and death you have all the destruction that follows so the image is there but it's so
marred so we have to ask this question how can we fulfill our God given purpose as image bearers
in a world full of sin turn to Colossians chapter one that's where we see it God ensured that he
would be glorified in this world by sending his son so Colossians chapter one verse 14 says that God
has delivered us from the domain of darkness and transferred us to the kingdom of his beloved son
in whom we have redemption the forgiveness of sins then hear what he says about Jesus
he is the image of the invisible God the firstborn of all creation so yes we are created in the image
of God but Jesus is the image of God so he perfectly reflects the character of his father
because all of the fullness of God and his righteousness dwells in him so we were created
as royal representatives but when Jesus comes to the world he is the very king himself among us
he is the royal son who reigns over all of creation
so yes we are rebels so why did the king come to us was it to destroy us no the king came into
the world because he loved us he came to serve and he came ultimately that we might be reconciled to God
so he's the perfect image of the invisible God but there on the cross his body is broken for us
so we might be forgiven and reconciled to God and then the king rises again from the dead
and because he rose again we can have new life in him and it is being united to Christ
by faith that the image of God is fully restored in us and God sees us united to Christ he sees us in the
very righteousness of him so another way of saying this is our identity is found in Christ
and the way we live out our purpose in the world is through him and by being conformed into his
image so once we're given this new life in Christ God works in us so we might live out the purpose we
were made for if you look at claustrians 3 and verse 10 paul says this to christians he says
put on the new self which is being renewed in the knowledge after the image of its creator
so Jesus is the image of God and if we are in christ God is at working in us so that the
image of our creator might be renewed in us so that through christ and by the help of his spirit
we might reflect his character in the world around us so through christ yes we can reflect
God's glory in the world we look to him and we're changed into his likeness through christ we rule
over God's creation but we do so in the way that jesus rules how does jesus rule he does so by
serving by laying down his life and love for others so yes we rule but in a way that's caring for
and cultivating for the good of others and for the glory of God through christ we reproduce God's
image now family is still important this creation order and institution remains but God's eternal
family ultimately grows and brings him glory in the world as we make disciples as more people
come to know christ God's image is reproduced and multiplied as we make disciples locally and globally
in christ and live by his grace for his glory in the world in the hope that we might one day
as the scripture says in 1st Corinthians 1549 that last verse in your worship guide
points looks forward to the day when we are with the Lord it says just as we have borne the
image of the man of dust we shall also bear the image of the man of heaven let's pray
Lord you created us and your design for our lives is good
and Lord we we want to confess and acknowledge before you this morning that
so often we fail to reflect your glory in the world Lord that we instead of
following your commands as our king we we rebel against you and we go our own way
Lord we thank you so much that you loved us enough to come into this world
to die in our place
that we might be reconciled to you it's Lord I pray that we would be a people who would find our
identity in Jesus Lord that we would come to you as yes people have sinned against you but people
who know that you love us and welcome us to yourself and long to restore us to yourself
and renew the image of God in us it's Lord we come to you now I pray that you'd help us to
look to you by faith and Lord I pray that you would ever increasingly conform us to the
image of Christ I pray all this in his name amen